[Musique]
maintenant que la maladie après c'est
sûr que sa douleur là elle va elle va se
répéter elle va rester là des fous du
fait que s'intensifier aussi
avec les actionnaires ne sait plus quoi
faire pour toujours travaillé il faut
commencer avec une relation de confiance
puis après j'ose espérer que les choses
peuvent cheminer d'helmand jégo jusqu'au
d'auteuil d'origine pourront commander
dans mon travail
il ya beaucoup le sentiment d'empathie
plutôt que d'en à gazinet sa tristesse
bien que triste pour elle je me dis ben
il faut que jamais notre notre neutre
notre rencontre positivement je reviens
sur ces questions sur ses priorités
juste prendre maman la de reprendre la
personne dans son entière et si c'est
difficile de passer après dans la
journée j'aimerais sur quelques rues
plus loin jusqu'en mai par des oiseaux
je pense que les conflits d'horaire le
manque de temps la surcharge de travail
plus nous amener à négliger certaines
parties de l'ecoute qu'on doit forcément
avoir dans le métier d'infirmière si on
regarde les heures supplémentaires ça
compte par centaines de milliers
seulement au chum on dit ça augmenté de
38% en deux ans vous est ce que ça vous
arrive d'en faire du temps
supplémentaire
ben on en fait toujours du temps
tout ça peut être traduit de différentes
façons la plupart du temps je mange de
mon écran je le prends pas
nécessairement pour ce seul avec mes
collègues
il peut arriver que j'amène des travaux
à la maison pour terminer on n'est pas
censé de face mais on doit le faire pour
être capable d'en arriver d'arriver dans
notre notre horaire puis être capable de
sentir accompli il va y avoir des
nouveaux projets pilotes pour encadrer
le ratio entre les professionnels et les
infirmières
mais n'empêche un sondage récemment qui
disait que les infirmières 30% d'entre
elles songent à quitter leur métier en
raison de la surcharge de travail vous
qu'est ce qui vous anime encore dans
votre métier
ce qui me stimule le plus je te dirai
serait vraiment contact avec la
clientèle de savoir que je des êtres que
ce soit directement ou indirectement
censeurs je serai pas infirmière moi
j'ai besoin d'engager une relation où je
vois que l'espace où on peut êter rage
et on peut sentir que ça serait le chaos
mais ça serait très difficile sans en
informer